the refugees behind me are crossing from
ukraine into poland and into the
european union but even with a war
raging there are calls to make both
sides of this border a part of the eu
eight member states signed an open
letter monday saying ukraine deserves to
receive immediate consideration for
membership as an official membership
candidate state among the countries
making that call poland slovakia and the
czech republic now one country going
even further in its call is ukraine
itself president zielenski held a
signing ceremony monday making a formal
request to join the union immediately
it's a process that normally takes years
zolensky wants it fast tracked through a
process that right now doesn't exist
he says ukrainians have won the right to
be with europe on equal terms and that
the time has come while there were some
positive overtures over the weekend from
eu leadership monday the organization's
foreign policy chief said there are more
immediate issues to worry about believe
me we have to do for more practical
things
membership is something that will late
in any case a lot of years we have to
provide an answer for the coming hours
not for the coming year the coming hours
the eu hasn't added a new country since
croatia in 2013. there are five
countries already in the process waiting
to join now one issue working against
ukraine is that the eu has a mutual
defense pact if an eu member state is
attacked other members have an
obligation to assist that would
effectively put the eu at war with
russia something it's trying to avoid
mike armstrong global news medica poland